the other significance of the result is
the one already considered that is the
significance of an observational
activity that dispenses with the notion
this knows no other way of understanding
and expressing itself than naively
asserting the reality of
self-consciousness to lie in the bone
just as it exists in a sensuous thing
and which at the same time does not lose
its objectivity for consciousness it has
no clear consciousness however of what
is implied in its assertion and does not
grasp the specific character of the
subject and predicate and their relation
in its proposition still less in the
sense of the infinite self suspending
judgment and of the notion rather out of
a profounder self-consciousness of
spirit which here appears as a natural
honesty it conceals from itself that is
gracefulness of the irrational crude
thought which takes a bone for the
reality of self-consciousness and it
white washes that thought by
unthinkingly mixing up with it all sorts
of relationships of cause and effect of
sign organ etc which are meaningless
here and it hides the crudity of the
proposition by distinctions derived from
them
we're now almost at the end of the
physiognomies and phrenology section
we're in the penultimate paragraph
number 345 Hagel has just been telling
us over and over again in a number of
different ways how the perspective that
the fizzy the physiognomist and then the
phrenologist is sort of a specific type
has been fundamentally mistaken about
the nature of human subjectivity of
agency and of what we can predict and
it's thereby lost any sort of pretense
to really being scientific and you know
we can we can save and this is sort of a
side note there's a lot of ways in which
people can appear and can even convince
themselves at what they're doing really
is genuinely scientific and yet at the
same time get things fundamentally wrong
by not thinking something through and
that's really what he's talking about in
this paragraph there's kind of a you
might say a repression of perspective so
that the person who's committed to doing
things from the perspective of
physiognomies doesn't have to take into
account what what's really going on in
terms of spirit in terms of the
dialectic and they can pretend to have a
scientific perspective that they don't
really have a right to so he says the
significance of the result that we've
been looking at is one already consider
the significance of what Miller
translates here is an observational
activity that dispenses with the notion
and so I've simplified this a little bit
being closer to the German observation
that dispenses with the notion even the
notion of dispensing here is a little
bit reading into it it's strictly
speaking begin flossin the concept
lesser notion list the old baktun so
observation that well you could say that
it dispenses with the notion or it slips
away from it or lose
site of it in any case what is going on
here is if lost sight of the notion and
so what what is it doing instead he says
it knows no other way of understanding
and expressing itself than naively
asserting the reality of
self-consciousness to lie in the bone
just as it exists as a sensuous thing
and we've we've looked at this now quite
a bit you know there's that that
lapidary statement spirit is a bone and
Hegel saying no of course it's not but
that's what the phrenologist is is
making it out to be and he says in which
at the same time does not lose its
objectivity for consciousness and this
points us towards the fundamental
problematic right so if the reality of
self-consciousness is taken to be a bone
existing as a sensuous thing as
something that we can look at directly
and we can feel we can measure if that's
supposed to be the reality of
self-consciousness what has not been
taken into account just a paragraph or
so earlier Hagel is talking about on
boxing people on the ears and and
actually needing to penetrate into their
skull why because that would show them
that if you really think
self-consciousness is just or any other
spiritual reality for that matter is
just a dead lifeless thing a bone well
then you have to explain how it is that
that self-consciousness is indeed
self-consciousness how is it taking
account of that how is it able to
construe itself as being a bone how is
it able to say that about the other
self-consciousness were the one that
would box it on the ear right or drill
into its head so what Hagel is going to
tell us here it is really quite
interesting he says it has no clear
consciousness of what is implied in this
assertion it's making an assertion it's
making a claim Hagel is going to turn
this into the language of
the proposition was a subject and a
predicate Hagel's saying it doesn't
fully understand what it's doing in
terms of the subject in the predicate he
says it doesn't grasp the specific
character of the subject and the
predicate what is the subject and the
predicate in this case well if the if
we're taking it at a literal level it's
this notion that the bone is the reality
of self-consciousness right because when
we when we predicate something on the
subject we are saying that the subject
is in a certain way or has a certain
characteristic or something can be said
about it that's what predication means
now of course you know this takes on a
somewhat different and fuller meeting
with in dialectical philosophy we don't
need to go too deep into that there's
plenty about that in the preface and
there's plenty of discussion of that in
other places suffice it to say that what
the self-consciousness who's claiming
that reality its reality lies in its
skull or anybody's self conscious
reality lies in their skull it's not
taking account of the fact that it's
making a claim that can be examined in
this term so it says it doesn't grasp
the specific character of the subject
what's that the bone it doesn't grasp
the specific character of the predicate
that is the reality of
self-consciousness and we could also
turn it the other way where
self-consciousness is the subject being
a bone having its reality as a bone is
the predicate it's not taking account of
what these things really are so he says
it doesn't take account of that and less
in the sense of the infinite self
suspending judgment and of the notion so
if it's not taking account of that it's
definitely not going to grasp things in
terms of the concept of the notion it's
like we said we Griff flow isn't it is
lacking in the concept or it is outside
of the concept in a certain way right
reduced from the concept so he says here
it appears as natural honesty it
conceals from itself the disgraceful
pneus of an the irrational crude thought
which takes the bone as a reality of
self-consciousness and it white washes
that thought by unthinkingly mixing it
up so instead of dealing with the the
self-contradiction that's going on it
starts talking about other stuff it uses
other language cause and effect we've
looked at that in the last how many
paragraphs what is the cause and what is
supposed to be the effect in terms of
the skull or the brain or whatever and
the spiritual reality of the person sign
and signified Hagel here just talks
about the sign remember that whenever
Hagel talks about the sign he means the
arbitrary non motivated linguistic sign
or other type of sign it doesn't have a
direct connection to the signified it's
just a conventional thing another text
in terms of organ and with Oregon what
would be the correlative to that is
going to cause an effect or sign
signified perhaps organ to function or
organ as expression of something organ
as the tool right was what organ
literally means and so by talking about
all of this it can stay at this level
and not grasp what is really going on
what it's really asserting and thereby
doesn't have to take into account what
it is in a certain sense responsible for
why not skulls can't be responsible
self-consciousness is can
brain fibers and the like when regarded
as the being of spirit are no more than
a merely hypothetical reality existing
only in one's head not the true reality
which has an outer existence and which
can be felt and seen when they exist out
there when they are seen they are dead
objects and then no longer pass for the
being of spirit but objectivity proper
must be an immediate sensuous
objectivity so that in this dead
objectivity for the bone is a dead thing
so far as what is dead is present in the
living being itself spirit is explicitly
present as actual the notion underlying
this idea is that reason takes itself to
be all thing hood even purely objective
thing hood itself but it is this only in
the notion or only the notion is the
truth of this idea and the pure of the
notion itself is the sillier and idea it
becomes when it's content is in the form
not of the notion but if picture
thinking that is if the self suspending
judgment is not taken with the
consciousness of this it's infinitude
but it has a fixed proposition the
subject and predicate of which are valid
each on its own account the cell fixed
itself the thing fixed is thing and yet
each is supposed to be the other reason
essentially the notion is directly
sundered into itself and its opposite in
antithesis which for that very reason is
equally immediately resolved but when
reason is presented as its own self and
its opposite and has held fast in the
entirely separate moment of this a
sundered pneus it is apprehended
irrationally on the pure of the moments
of this asunder pneus the cruder is the
appearance of this contest which is
either only for consciousness or only
ingenuously expressed by it the depth
which spirit brings forth from within
but only as far as its picture thinking
consciousness where it lets it remain
and the ignorance of this consciousness
about what it really is saying
are the same conjunction of the high and
the low which in the living being nature
naively expresses when it combines the
organ of its highest fulfillment the
organ of generation which it with the
organ of urination the infinite judgment
qua infinite would be the fulfillment of
life that comprehends itself the
consciousness of the infinite judgment
that remains at the level of picture
thinking behaves as urination
we don't frequently find Hagel indulging
in too much humor and tends to be pretty
dry you have to read between the lines
to find it but I think arguably here at
the end of paragraph 346 we actually
have a joke and we not only have a joke
we have a fairly crude dick joke going
on as Hagel talks about the same organ
the organ of the highest fulfillment of
nature the organ of generation being
combined with the organ of urination and
how the perspective of picture thinking
or forced Ellen finds itself confuted
and confronted by this this bifurcation
of the very same thing so you know again
this is not on the surface you have to
dig a little bit to really get it but I
think once we go through it it'll be a
nice ending for this long long passage
where the the meaning of things has been
identified with organs or with with
physiognomies or phrenology anyway so
it's really quite a fitting way to end
things so Hangul starts out by talking
about brain fibers he says brain fibers
and the like when regarded as the being
of spirit are no more than a merely
hypothetical reality existing only in
one's head not the true reality which
has an outer existence that's a very
interesting thing to say Hagel is not
particularly interested in say mapping
out the brain as other people were in
his own time and people are quite wild
about in our own time he says if we're
going to talk about external things
let's actually take it seriously and you
know consider this notion that maybe
spirit is a bone of course he is
rejecting this but he's rejecting it on
the way to something what's the
something the whole rest of the reason
section and the spirit section yet to
come which is the bulk of of the
phenomenology of spirit we're only
really getting to the the serious stuff
now
and Hagel says no no you know brain
stuff is really in our head in two
different ways it is in our head it's
the wet where the goop that remember
that that organ that he talked about in
a previous paragraph through which the
the body knows itself he's willing to go
with that it's the organ that is the
seat of spirit but our conceptions of
the brain and what it's actually doing
are actually in our head in either
representation what we're calling
picture thinking or grasped conceptually
through the griff right through the
notion you can't actually see your own
brain I mean there are those interesting
scenes or somebody's head is opened up
and maybe they could be looking in a
mirror or something like that but we can
observe other people's brains we can't
actually observe what's really going on
in them all we have are proxies this is
something that we can talk much more
about but I don't want to get too bogged
down in it because i want you to see
where Hagel is really going with this
Hagel goes on and he says objectivity
proper must be an immediate sensuous
objectivity so that in this dead
objectivity for the bone is a dead thing
so far as what is dead is present in the
living being itself spirit is explicitly
present as actual that's worth reading
again objectivity proper must be an
immediate sensuous objectivity so that
in this dead objectivity now jump right
to the end spirit is explicitly present
as actual the actual ative spirit is not
the bone but the bone has to be there
Hagel stresses to us over and over again
both in the phenomenology and in the
science of logic and in so many other
works that we can't really talk about
something as being purely interior
the essence of something had better be
appearance it better show itself it had
better do something it better exhibit
itself within the world it better make
itself as he's saying here explicit and
so it's not purely accidental that we do
have these bulbs right it's I mean we
could imagine other shapes we could
imagine other ways in which rationality
can be present in the universe but this
is the one that we've got this is what
we've got to work with this is what we
have to observe we're in the middle of
observing reason or rather at the end of
observing reason so he says that the
notion underlying this idea is that
reason takes itself to be all thing good
even purely objective thing hood itself
so we have a transition here what is
what is to be gained in all of this
reason you remember at the very
beginning of the observing reason
section Hagel said that we made this
transition from self-consciousness and
all the problematics going on their
reason now takes itself to be all
reality what reason has been developing
what reason has been examining is well
what is all that reality and reason
takes itself like he says to be not only
self conscious reality but all thing
good living things dead things the whole
complex of the universe reason is able
to take as its domain it's very
ambitious but this is what modern
philosophy took as it sits rallying call
whether in the empiricist version or in
the rationalist version or in the
idealist version that's going to come
out of that right so this is really
quite quite you know like I said quite
ambitious this is a call on Hagel's part
now he points out a problem that we're
going to run into you notice we've got
notion here
the grave and then we've also got
picture thinking here and we have to
make a sort of choice between them or a
choice winds up getting made for us and
we can not only talk about individual
reasoner's we can talk about entire
philosophical and scientific movements
aligning themselves with this Hagel will
talk in other places about philosophies
of the understanding by that he means
philosophies that are not operating on
the level of feeling but are operating
with force telling with with picture
thinking he would consider for example
John Locke to be an eminent example of
this sort of thing that's why lock in
philosophy leads us to certain dead ends
and gets us caught at certain conundrums
he would also consider Rene Descartes to
be largely caught up in picture thinking
as well so both rationalist and
empiricists are liable to this we what
we want is the the notion the grip and
we'll talk about that a bit more he says
the notion underlying this idea is that
reason takes itself to be all things
even purely objective thing good but it
is this only in the notion remember we
have to distinguish sometimes between
the fully developed notion and the
notion as the starting point and here
he's using notion in both of these these
ways so he says it's only the notion is
the truth of this idea the pure the
notion itself is the sillier an idea it
becomes when its content is in the form
the form that's not appropriate to it we
have form versus content when the form
is that of picture thinking we have
content that is dynamic and we try to
fit it into a static way of
understanding it a way that is ruled by
not fully understanding how
contradiction works or negativity works
or mediation works these key ideas that
Hagel keeps coming back to over and over
again and the person who's caught up in
picture thinking they may have a sense
that there's something wrong but they
have a very hard time grasping why they
should make a trans
to this messy stuff over here that seems
rather unrests but it only you can only
see the rigor of it when you actually
immerse yourself within the system as it
develops so there's kind of a catch-22
isn't there so he goes on and he says
the sillier the idea becomes when its
content is in the form of picture
thinking that is and he says here if the
self suspending judgment and the German
for that self suspending judgment okay
the judgment is an earth I'll write a
judgment but the self suspending their
Zeke Zeb's of he banned remember elf hey
bong is this process of not only just
canceling or transcending but it brings
along at least the outlines of what it
is that it was transcending dad is
integral to conceptual thinking to add
also you might say even this may be a
little bit of heretical said it's
conceptual acting but a flick is handled
if we want to use that sort of language
that's not available from the
perspective of picture thinking of
forced elam of representation so what's
going to happen that all right he goes
on and he says if the cell suspending
judgment is not taken with the
consciousness of this it's infinitude
but as a fixed proposition the subject
and predicate of which are valid each on
its own account the self fixed itself
the thing fixed this thing and yet each
is supposed to be the other so what are
we talking about here right the self
spirit the thing the bone more broadly
reason takes itself to be all thing HUD
that's the thing the self if we
understand these things from the
perspective of forced along it's no
surprise then that's saying well these
are somehow self cancelling and and the
same thing but not this
same thing you know we talked earlier
and you know forcing the understanding
about the self-same repulses itself and
draws to itself its other all of that
language all of that that you know
verbiage all that those concepts or
notions they don't make sense within
this perspective and there give me a lot
of different ways of doing for shallow
but ultimately they're all going to boil
down to the same thing none of them are
going to be adequate and none of them
even if you sit there and you explain
until you're blue in the face are going
to get across what is going on in this
this sort of development so he goes on
and he says reason essentially the
notion winds up directly sundered into
itself and its opposite reason winds up
finding itself opposed to the thing and
the thing opposed to it and is held fast
in the entirely separate moment of the
sundered pneus when that happens when
reason is presented as its own self and
its opposite it is apprehended ear
rationally reason winds up being
unreason reason winds up becoming
irrational again what happens when we
lapse into picture thinking and it says
the pure the moments of this asunder
pneus the cruder is the appearance of
this content which is either only for
consciousness or ingenuously expressed
by it and so the person who is engaging
in picture thing is it look there's this
is an antenna me this is an antithesis
this is something that we cannot get
past this can't be made sense of who's
Hagel targeting here Hagel has a lot of
targets going on here in modern
philosophy I leave that to you to think
about and to think about whether some of
Hegel's own interpreters who stress the
irrational perhaps more than they ought
to couldn't be brought into his
crosshairs as well I mean I'll suggest
to you
that as I put it out you know what he
calls philosophies of the understanding
likes a lock in philosophy are not going
to be any good in this respect and so
people like lock or hobbs would say yes
that's an absurdity that doesn't make
sense you know this this way in which
your understanding reason and historical
development and consciousness I think
God would fall in there as well I think
you might even be able to say that this
although i don't think that Hagel is
actually you know deliberately doing
this could be a Hegelian response to
Schopenhauer or other people who are
talking about this sort of thing so he
goes on and he says the depth which
spirit brings forth from within but only
as far as its picture thinking
consciousness where lets it remain and
the ignorance of this consciousness
about what it really is saying are the
same conjunction of the high and the low
which in the living being nature naively
expresses here we get to the stuff about
the organ of generation with the penis
right with is combined with the organ of
urination it does double duty right
nature plays a cruel or capricious joke
upon us by mixing these things together
then that's that's in the case of the
male we could also talk in the case of
the female right we're both cases the
organ of generation and the Oregon of
urination are the same thing and why the
hell is that in nature doing that so why
are there mixing up the highest and the
lowest and you know it's funny too
because Hagel's not saying as a many
earlier thinkers with all sexuality
that's just a lowly thing a thing of the
flesh he's saying that's the highest
that's what the highest function is
generation is reproduction right he's
not saying sexual pleasure is the
highest of course so you might seem a
little prudish with respect to that but
I mean who's really going to say the
sexual pleasures de absolute highest
thing
muster say even desaad doesn't say that
sort of thing right nor do the
epicureans but urination is a pretty low
function right you're just eliminating
bodily wastes so what does Hangul saying
here those picture thinking people they
can't make sense of this anymore that
they can make sense of the fact that the
same organ is used for reproduction and
used for urination they can't understand
the penis or the phallus or whatever you
want to call it right they can represent
it they can do a for styling of it as a
matter of fact they probably have all
sorts of things like that doodled on
their notebooks but they can't grasp it
conceptually they're unable to see how
to things you know high and low could
actually be combined in the same thing
and that that could in fact be rational
that that could make sense so he says
the infinite judgment qua infinite would
be the fulfillment of life that
comprehends itself of course the
comprehend the consciousness of the
infinite judgment that remains at the
level of picture thinking behaves as
urination he's literally saying they're
pissing things away or if we want to you
know joke around a little bit further
with this going beyond the text and what
hegel might say they're kind of pissing
me off I mean I don't think that low
cution exists in German but we might say
they're just pissing around it has no
value and so what does this tell us well
this tells us two things and this is
very important so it's fun to end on a
joke and maybe we can come back to that
in a moment but what we do want to
remember is this is the ending of a
section and whenever Hagel is ending a
section in the phenomenology that's
because something has been achieved some
out hey bong some transcendence some sub
latian has reached a new gestalt the new
form of consciousness that's what we're
moving into next so two things one is
that now once again reason
is trying to make sense out of itself it
is exhausted at least for the moment
observation and now is going to turn to
the examination of the individual human
being understood in terms of thing who
had but also understood in terms of
agency we also have to remember the
logic of representation is not going to
be adequate for what we're trying to do
and we have to follow the lead of the
concept however difficult that is
however frustrating that is however in
you know not infuriating but confusing
that winds up being we hope as we go
through it and I can tell you having
gone through it many times the next
section is going to make a lot of sense
and we're still working with this
dynamic of spirit trying to find itself
in a world that in a way is its own and
in a way is alien to it so I suppose we
should end on some sort of comedy rather
than a moment of you know seriousness I
think it's funny by itself that Hagel is
making what read between the lines is in
effect a philosophical dick joke and so
that's probably a funny enough way to
end this video
you